does your neighborhood have like uh a
gang of old japanese grandmas who are
just like who are just like who are just
like the real
you know
the leaders of that [ __ ] street or
whatever because you have a house oh
yeah i have a house yeah you're in like
a neighborhood area yeah i'm in an
apartment so yeah okay yeah i'm in an
apartment as well yeah because melin
like warned me about this before before
i was moving in the house and she was
like be careful about the posse of old
japanese grandmas and i'm just like what
are you talking about melin what are you
talking about and lo and behold like
like now i've noticed like there's there
is this group of japanese grandmas who
like seem to run the neighborhood i
don't i don't know i don't know how this
happens i don't know why this happened
but you do one you do like one thing
wrong like maybe you take the garbage
out just a bit too early you see them
you see them eyeing you you see them
eyeing you right yeah i can tell anytime
anytime me and sydney come out like we
could we like sometimes they're just
like gossiping together right like you
know when you can you know when you
could feel someone gossiping about you
that's every time like me and sydney go
out of the house and like they're always
in the same corner it's the same group
of same group of japanese grandma and i
remember we should wait for them and say
hi yeah yeah you should yeah for those
people you what i've learned is that you
just need to be like ignorantly like
happy and friendly towards them and then
they'll start to be like oh maybe maybe
they're actually all right maybe we'll
we'll take them off the hit list you
know
i feel like okay i feel like i've been
put i was friendly enough right it was
the most moist thing i'm sorry
yeah but i i i feel like i've been put
on a hit list now because uh i did
unfortunately take the garbage out on
the wrong day one day
being on a japanese hit list is just
like i'll give you at worst a passive
aggressive note one day yeah i got that
yeah yeah yeah
yeah i remember i i in my old apartment
i got that english written note yeah
yeah that's the worst you'll get yeah
they say
they say they'll kick you out and then
they'll they'll tell the housing company
and then i need hong kong
card and then they shut up yeah the
housing company is not going to kick you
out of course unless you are actually
taking the piss but if you're just
walking they're not gonna then the
housing companies not gonna give a [ __ ]
yeah they'll be like okay granny they'll
be like all right simmer down come on
so yeah say one one day like uh
normally we take our garbage out either
like the night before or like the
morning of i don't know what's custom in
in japanese neighborhoods
it depends on your area yeah normally
it's like i think the morning of yeah
but i remember i think we woke i woke up
like slightly late that day so how it
works in my place is that um the garbage
is one day and then like the recyclables
is the next day
um
i think that's most i think it's most
places yeah yes so
i i thought like i was just on the cusp
of like getting like uh getting the
recyclables out on the right day yeah
because it's garbage recyclables and
garbage again yeah um and so i thought i
was just on the cast maybe maybe the
garbage truck hadn't come yet so i go
out to the garbage sport and i see like
some bags there i was like oh great i
still i still
met uh i still made it in time yeah and
so i put i put the recyclables out went
back in my house and just continued
about my day and then i i get i get a
ring on my doorbell oh no i'm gonna ring
my doorbell and i'm just like and i'm
just like oh it must be uh it must be a
delivery or something yeah and it's uh i
opened the door and it's a
three-year-old japanese grandmaster just
staring at me
yeah i i am serious
and i see my uh my bag of recyclables
right uh right uh right in front of my
door right and uh they um i mean they
they they nicely enough explained to me
that it was uh that i had missed the
time and it was the wrong day to bring
out the to bring out the recyclables but
it kind of felt like some [ __ ] loan
sharks outside my door being being like
it would be a shame if this would have
happened again yeah yeah it's like repo
man
you do it again we're taking everything
they are basically like the gangsters
that run the neighborhood you know i
felt like i just like missed out on the
day of law on like paying the protection
money of the day it's like shame shame
what would happen if america has the
crips and the blood so we have
it's like the [ __ ] sopranos right you
know it's the japanese sopranos right
the old japanese groundbreaking
recycling out today yes
some really strict crazy grandmas you
can get pissed off when like you know on
like cardboard boxes yeah like the
amazon labels and stuff yeah they get
like pissed off you don't take those off
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah some grandmas
that get like how dare you yeah even
though it doesn't doesn't make a
difference yeah of course yeah i like
this is why i love love living in an
apartment building i just take it down
whenever i want yeah yeah no no
recycling day
no garbage day whenever you have garbage
take it down cardboard's the worst
because when you're moving in it
literally is like cardboard city oh yeah
yeah and it's just like stacks upon
stacks upon stack and waiting for the
day when you're like what's that in the
corner well it's the wall of cardboard
actually it's one of the main
attractions of the apartment and i have
so much cardboard in fact that i could
probably uh you know house everyone in
the half of japan yeah i mean that's
that's the thing where i remember when i
was moving in i
i felt like
if you missed the day of the cardboard
collection then you were just like you
were just [ __ ] right yeah yeah but
also you feel like am i taking the piss
with this much cardboard like i have
like
like a two meter high stack of cardboard
am i am i taking up too much cardboard
is that allowed what's the limit on how
much recycling i can recycle i remember
the only time i had like a granny
experience uh
uh when i was moving into my current
place was when when it was like the
first week i was moving in and you know
it was like the shitload of cardboard
thing right yeah yeah and cardboard day
comes around i'm just like finally here
we go this is this is where the
cleansing starts right so i take out
like way too much cardboard like
probably [ __ ] half the amazon
rainforest worth of cardboard right
naturally and then uh
and then uh that the next morning i i
come out you know to to leave for the
office right and and a grandma like
stops me
and she's and i'm like oh no
oh wow
and uh she points at the mountain of
cardboard and she's like
that's that's all your cardboard right
yeah and i was like i mean not all of it
but yeah like come on laura it's like
ninety percent it's like it's like yeah
like yeah most of it and she's like i
think uh that you know you're really
causing the the you know rubbish people
a lot of trouble with that much
cardboard and then i just reverse uno
card and i'm like i moved in yesterday
was just like oh i'm sorry then i'm
sorry about that
yeah but that felt good that was the one
time where i trumped the granny i was
like you don't control it
silence silence woman
actually um some moving companies like
call them up yeah yeah yeah yeah i did
that but even they i had so much
cardboard that the moving company could
only take so much yeah cardboard yeah
because i bought like because i bought
because you know i moved into a much
bigger place and i needed to buy all
this new furniture to fill up the space
so yeah yeah but it's not good felt good
to reverse
granny basically you know they think
like organized crime in japan is the
yakuza no just it's the
it's the japanese grannies in your
neighborhood watch out make sure you
don't piss them off otherwise you're
gonna be having a bad time i've been
leaving you for six years i know every
nook and cranny of these streets
literally the day after they came like i
came back i came back home and uh they
slid this in my letterbox just like the
schedule the garbage for like the week
and the garbage collection
i was just like i was just like oh this
is they're sending me a message
they're literally
get the garbage day right next time
don't [ __ ] up dad's shaman at the front
so you better take this out on the right
day
what day what day does oily containers
go gone
a shampoo bottle is not recycling oh my
god
i love it you have this like spreadsheet
of like items that very specifically
cannot be recycled and stuff i have an
app for it dude oh my god yeah like our
ward created an app being like if you
put in a certain item it tells you
exactly what day what sucks is that
there's like some items you're like what
the [ __ ] is this it's like it's like you
know like styrofoam right yeah where
have you had that packaging that's like
thin
it's like a paper styrofoam yeah yeah
like what the [ __ ] is this is this
burnable is this paper is this plastic i
don't know what this is this is a
mystery and every time i ask anyone that
like i have no idea i i think it's
burnable but no one's like 100 they're
like
everyone's like dude it's not going to
matter just put it in the bowl that's
the thing it's like there's all these
rules that are laid out that like the
grannies will enforce you on but like
yeah when you put it all into a [ __ ]
bag it just didn't put it out i heard i
heard i heard that apparently the
recycling even though they they make you
shorter very strict that actually when
it goes to the plant apparently i don't
know how true this is it's not actually
like they don't recycle it as well as
you think they are yeah yeah yeah
i would believe that yeah i mean fair
enough yeah um but
[ __ ] dude i i one time i went down to my
recycling thing in my current place
i thought hmm i was just i was putting
out my bottles in the bottle thing and i
noticed that there was like
10 plus bombay sapphire
gin bottles right and i was like who who
has drank this much bombay sapphire
this is a lot of wasn't europe
i was gonna say i thought that was like
as another person who enjoys bombay
sanctuary and i was like huh i wonder
who's bought this much bombay well i'm
gonna keep saying it's very satisfying
bomb based safari there's another
british person in your building i was
like either somebody's
running a bar secretly in their
apartment that specializes in bombay
sapphire cocktails someone had a good
night well there's a really depressed
british person somewhere in this
apartment building who is really
really spending a lot of money on gin
yeah i just thought why would you have
this many they're all neatly stacked
like almost like a jenga-esque stacking
style i'm like this is impressive this
is definitely one person who brought i
wonder did they collect them for a long
time they thought no this is ridiculous
i can't collect this many bottles
because somebody will keep their alcohol
containers afterwards yeah yeah yeah
it's like a memory but yeah i guess when
you drink too much you're like yeah okay
how many how many bombay sapphires is
too many i just thought i was like this
is a lot i'm like yeah what's going on
here i i wonder i was like what a weird
trash do you see people's trash and you
think what's going on oh yeah yeah get
on with that many times i remember the
weirdest one i saw was uh it was a
vacuum cleaner that had been perfectly
cut in half down the middle
it was like a dyson it was like the body
of a dyson but it had been perfectly
split down the middle but there was only
one half and i'm like where did the
other half a serial killer yeah just one
half yeah it was only one half and i was
i was kind of i was like for like five
minutes i was kind of looking around
seeing like i wonder where the other
half is i couldn't find it so he's
either kept the other half or i've
witnessed uh some crucial evidence of a
crime scene or something like i don't
know what
it was the weirdest thing at least i was
like oh well now i know what's inside of
a dyson
that's like something you see like a
youtube channel yeah i know how what
happened what's inside of a dice inside
of a dyson what if i cut this dyson in
perfectly i just wanted i just want to
know how they did it
they must have like that it's either
someone has a laser cutter inside of
their house or they just went ham with a
saw i don't know what it was either they
have a saw in their house yeah it's
somewhere else and then they brought
half a dozen to your apartment
building and then they decided that they
are done with half a dice and they're
gonna throw it away it was the weirdest
thing i've ever seen so annoying having
to get rid of big stuff in japan it is
you buy those stupid stickers from the
convenience you can't throw out a
if it's bigger than i think 30
centimeters in my
something like that which is nothing
yeah there's so many things that are 30
centimeters or bigger and if you want to
throw it away you have to book and it's
normally like three weeks away if you're
lucky yeah usually it's like a month so
normally now i figured out a genius
strat which is just break the thing down
yeah below 30 seconds oh yeah yeah yeah
and then you're good yeah yeah it's like
it's like uh you know how like in the
prison movies right when they when they
escape from prison that they start
dumping the soil like one by one yeah in
the courtyard or something yeah yeah
that's like all right you gotta you
gotta break this water this cabinet into
like small pieces and slowly recycle it
every week
yes actually i saw that the other day
actually people do it because they don't
want to deal with because this [ __ ] is
so annoying
someone had disposed of an office chair
one part at a time
i get it i get it that's so genius i
remember because like i remember seeing
like i would go take the garbage out and
one day i'd saw like the bottom off so
like the wheels part and i'm just like
well i saw i'm just getting rid of like
the [ __ ] wheels part and then the
next week i go go go to put the garbage
again and it's like the seat
then this is and then it's the seat and
i'm like oh someone's just playing jenga
with office chairs and then next week
should learn hold it's like the back
rest it's slow but it's a fake this is
the exact reason why i bought a saw
i'm not kidding i bought a sword just to
source [ __ ] oh yeah yeah i don't have to
deal with it i like a lot of wooden [ __ ]
and i'm just like i'm not paying to get
rid of this [ __ ] wooden plank i'm
just going to saw this yeah but it's
also it's also annoying because you have
to you have to measure it exactly yeah
yeah and if it's even a little bit off
that whether they won't take it yeah you
need to wait another three weeks and buy
those stupid sticker things again i
don't know i had like a metallic like
coat hanger or coat rack kind of thing
and of course it was like way too big
even if i took the parts off so what did
i do i i put it back up i put it on my
balcony and just let the weather wear it
down as much as possible so the point
where i could just snap it in here
i just let it rust to [ __ ] and then i
grab the saw or like just snap it in
half to the size i'm like perfect just
let nature take its course
erosion like three months later i was
like all right i can finally see the
worst way to recycle something but i
respect i respect the the the effort
you'd go to to not deal with the best
yeah yeah dude it probably would have
taken just as long to [ __ ] book a
time to throw this [ __ ] code hanger
out
i just yeah i just don't want to deal
with it yeah i just or i just wait for
someone to come over and be like do you
want this shitty thing i don't need just
take it dude they make me feel like such
a bastard for using batteries like i
just i just want to use some double-a
batteries yeah and they make it seem
like i was like like using like some
kind of radioactive material the way
they're gonna get rid of it i'm like
what's wrong with me yeah i don't think
i've ever like properly gotten rid of my
batteries right because i'm just like
okay i'll get rid of them next time the
other time um so i have like a [ __ ]
draw just full of like
use dead batteries that i've not been
able to get rid of because that is the
most draw in existence yeah oh i'm sure
we've got a whole drawer full of battery
sydney go go and grab a pair none of
them are working
that's what you should do is like a joke
just be like just get one like actually
working battery and put it in that drone
being like there was one working battery
in the world
i mean i'm so special i'm gonna get rid
of it someday but just like i i just
keep forgetting the day to get rid of
the batteries the most [ __ ] up saw
trap
there is one working battery you have 15
minutes
find the working battery
oh my god yeah i don't really use a lot
of batteries but for a lot of the uh
filming stuff that we have yeah it's
basically all for the filming stuff for
like yeah mics camera accessories it's
all batteries it's pretty annoying
because you have to
have to get batteries for that and it
kind of sucks i was like get
rechargeable ones yeah but i always
forget to recharge yeah yeah but then if
you get rechargeable ones you forget to
recharge the before the shoots which is
yeah and luckily you can you can buy aaa
batteries like everywhere yeah so yeah
pretty good for that it's pretty good
always always done well